it's Thursday March third and there's  been a ton of no man's sky news today if  you're looking to pick up a special  edition of the spacefaring game you have  two solid options this is Tony here with  an interstellar gamespot news update  first up is the $80 limited edition  available on disk for ps4 that includes  an art book to comic stories a dynamic  theme in game dlc and a steel case for  150 bucks you can pick up the Explorers  edition which includes a beautifully  hand-painted metal cast replica of the  in-game ship this version is capped at  10,000 units so you should act fast if  it catches your eye note that the game  itself is packed in as a steam coat no  man's sky launches for ps4 and pc on jun  21st and now you have plenty of options  for picking it up which one looks best  to you leave a comment then head to  gamespot for a bunch more coverage on no  man's sky